I want you to try something for a second
open your right hand now use your left
hand and pinch the index finger of your
right hand hard enough to sense the pain
how do you feel do you feel confused do
you feel angry do you feel scared do you
feel alert DFL life you know sometimes
all it takes to shift our focus from
frivolous and ordinary tasks to
something deeper is some pain before
watching this video you will most
probably occupy with some other video or
activity now I have your attention
pain has mainly two forms it can be
either the driver of change and a
reminder that our life isn't exactly
close to what we envisioned it to be or
it can be a devastating force that
leaves us powerless and reduces our
ability to objectively evaluate our
self-worth
the former is empowering the latter is
weakening your interpretation of pain
says a lot about your character and how
much you have invested in this
interpretation regardless of which form
you decide to embrace pain will
inevitably lead to a change in your
present state that change will create an
imbalance in your rational and
undoubtedly lead to the initiation of
decision-making processes pain is a tool
it is a tool used consciously and
unconsciously by many agents in most
facets of your life it is a very
effective motivator that can influence
specific choices that you make and
affect the areas that you decide to be
part of this lucid realization might
elicit mixed feelings within you but at
the same time it can empower your sense
of self-awareness pain is an omnipresent
force you can't avoid it but you can
definitely manage it this management is
not a matter of luck it is a matter of
introspection and making use of one of
the most powerful tools you will ever
encounter this tool is called Monk mode
the word monk derives from the Greek
word mana hos which means alone the monk
is a person who voluntarily decides to
isolate himself from mainstream society
and embrace an aesthetic mode of being
asceticism is a lifestyle characterized
by abstinence from worldly pleasures in
the pursuit of spiritual goals it is the
abrasion of an impulse driven state and
they emerge in a reality characterized
by self-control and balance monks have
been practicing asceticism many for
religious purposes there are aversion
towards contemporary societal values led
them to asceticism as the only way to
escape human nature and achieve theosis
or union with God for God is the
manifestation of spirituality and
enlightenment in our modern epoch monk
mode has been introduced as a way to
describe our attempt to hedge ourselves
from ongoing external stimuli our
proclivity to exposing ourselves to a
plethora of situations opinions and
activities leads to mental
disorientation and lack of control over
our emotional state we're still primal
creatures with a well-defined set of
needs and characteristics when those are
not met we revert to unorthodox
behaviors that's why monk mode becomes
imperative nowadays monk mode is a metal
stick that allows the individual to
assume control over his mental
well-being and eventually Oakman his
value in an attempt to revamp his life
conditions the monk mode framework
requires inquisitive analysis and the
best way to execute this analysis is
divided the framework into four areas
lack of self-delusion is the first and
probably the most defining
characteristic of a person who has
successfully internalized monk mode self
delusion is defined as the inability of
the individual to objectively evaluate
his or her strengths and weaknesses and
pursue ambitious and tangible goals it
can occur due to many reasons but the
most relevant one is the absence of
introspection and cell phone Steve the
idea you have about yourself is affected
by biases limiting beliefs and
brainwashing you're a malleable entity
that can be molded according to how
prone you are to external influence
people will throw at you different life
interpret
and you will unavoidably espouse um and
reject some becoming fixated on outdated
patterns and modes of thinking will
inevitably impede your attempt to reach
Munk mode that is because a person in
Munk mode is capable of readapting his
or her views and beliefs according to
well evaluated knowledge self delusion
has two sides the one side refers to the
delusion of superiority and the other
side refers to the delusion of
inferiority everyone of us has strengths
and weaknesses sadly most of us are
unaware of them because we never try to
identify them study yourself and learn
how to follow your skills if you lack
skills in a certain area have the
tenacity to pursue them for as long as
they can serve you this process is what
will eventually face self delusion and
give rise to self mastery Wikipedia in
this article suggests an exhaustive list
of cognitive biases we all suffer from
to some extent biases can also be
considered mental noise since they
contribute to the oftentimes cacophonous
mumbling of society a person in montt
mode is capable of performing regular
self checks with regards to his or her
ability to observe and evaluate observer
state is the detachment from ego and the
adoption of a bias-free mindset think of
it as a form of a wake lucid dreaming
you become aware of your dream and you
are able to assume partial control over
it I like to refer to that state as a
delicate mixture of pure emotional and
social awareness another important thing
to consider when assuming observer mode
is that there is no such thing as one
acceptable Universal moral truth there
are just perceptions and different of
rotations of reality and morality
Jonathan Hyde explains that argument in
the righteous mind if you think that
moral reasoning is something we do to
figure out the truth you'll be
constantly frustrated by how foolish
biased and illogical people become when
they disagree with you
Robert Greene reinforces that pointing
mastery people around you constantly
under the pool of their emotions change
their ideas by
day or by the hour depending on their
mood you must never assume that what
people say or do in a particular moment
is a statement of their permanent
desires this is what it is okay I said
empty your mind be formless shapeless
like water now you put water into a cup
it becomes the cup you put water into a
bottle it becomes the bottle you put in
a teapot it becomes the teapot now water
can flow or it can crash the water my
friend formlessness is nothing more than
adaptation it is the natural state of
man since the Darwinian evolutionary
theory suggests that evolution favors
the survival of the fittest species
adaptable to change in a world headed
towards more diversity and
multiculturalism formlessness becomes
imperative with monk mode a person
neither seeks to follow the ways of the
Ancients nor establishes any fixed
standard for all times but examines the
things of his age and then prepares to
deal with them in a strategic way life
is strategy after all
monk mode although it requires a certain
amount of isolation in order to allow
space for introspection to flourish
thrives with exposure when you spend the
majority of your time isolated within
the barriers of your comfort zone you
become self-conscious and frail
interaction with the real world is
inevitable and isolation just makes this
interaction more rigid as ice total
famously put it man is by nature a
social animal an individual who is
unsocial naturally and not accidentally
is either beneath our notice or more
than human society is something that
precedes the individual anyone who
either cannot lead the common life or is
so self-sufficient as not to need to and
therefore does not partake of society is
either a beast or a god instead of
aspiring to an idealistic view of the
world monk mode aims towards absolute
acceptance of human nature relationships
are hard but it is this hardship that
allows us to improve our ability to
co-exist become better at evaluating who
you are and who is a good match for you
harness your social intelligence
partaken social activities and use
observer mode to evaluate people's
responses and intentions monk mode is
without doubt one of the most
challenging pursuits many want to reach
it but few are ready to espouse the
mandatory pain and practice required
stepping out of your comfort zone
suppressing your ego becoming an
observer and adapting your behavior
might feel agonizing at first the thing
is that remaining stagnant and
perpetuating harmful habits and
practices is equally agonizing and so
slack of self-ownership
learn to own the idea of yourself and
use monk mode as a tool to manifest that
idea into reality hi everyone I want to
do this video for a while now not only
because I consider mock more the very
interesting mental state but also
because I wanted to explain that monk
mode isn't synonymous with isolation as
some people think yes
isolation is critical when it comes to
reengage in with ourselves but monk mode
is more about adopting characteristics
of a monk that will allow you to become
more anti fragile while
navigating yourself through life if you
enjoyed this video please like subscribe
and comment below something cool so that
it can gain more traction and I can keep
creating thought-provoking video essays
stay awesome see you soon adrián out
[Music]